I have to ask you about the turmoil in
the public markets we were seeing there
the SP down the tech-heavy Nasdaq down
almost 6% just in the last three days
how justified is that personally thank
you very much for being at our Global
Investment Research Tech in internet
conference we've got almost 2,000 people
here registered so we're having a great
conference great turnout so I appreciate
you being here and highlighting the
event so look the public markets clearly
will have an impact on the private
companies you know when you take a
company public you look at the
comparables that exist in the market
today and that's the first benchmark for
valuing any new offering is to look at
the similar companies and take your
evaluation benchmark or metric from what
exists out there so everyone is watching
what's going on in the public markets
too so LinkedIn for example I know they
had a weak forecast but is it really
worth half of what it was last week no
one can say for sure that it's worth
half of what it was or was worth what it
was the week before what investors are
trying to tell you today is that cash
flow and earnings matter the market is
now maturing for Internet and technology
companies they mean in a more mature
industry you start thinking about
earnings revenue cash flow not nearly as
much about growth historically the
technology companies have been valued on
growth and you put big growth multiples
on these companies as we're shifting
from a growth multiple to an earnings
multiple and a cashflow multiple we're
coming up with different valuations yes
it can be shocking to revalue a company
from a growth multiple to a earnings or
cashflow multiple but it's happening and
it's a natural evolution normally we see
it evolve over a longer period of time
for some reason or for a variety of
different reasons we're seeing it happen
relatively quickly in some of these
technology come so are we seeing a
massive revaluation of tech is that what
we're in your seat you're definitely
seeing a revaluation in some companies
you're seeing a massive revaluation
that's not saying that we can't go back
up to the old valuations but the market
is clearly taking a pause and trying to
stand the long term viability and the
long term wealth creation vehicle for
shareholders your boss said earlier
today that you're seeing pent up IPO
demand because private funding is drying
up our company is really thinking about
going public in a market as volatile as
this well the premise in many of these
technology companies for years has been
growth growth growth and we will be able
to get funding no matter what as long as
we're growing the will use this funding
to grow which will allow us to get the
next round of funding which will allow
us to grow if you can't get funding
it changes the premise to some extent
you now have to think about changing
your model from just pure growth to
creating cash flow to create creating
revenue creating return on capital if
you can create cash flow return on
capital you will have access to the
public market and buyers and investors
will show up at that point historically
companies have not wanted to go into the
public markets because the public
markets will at some point like we're
seeing now they will demand earnings
power they will demand some return on
capital they will demand that you
actually create revenue with that you
just don't grow your company forever so
what happens then to IPO volume in 2016
what happens to MA
how does 2016 compared to 2015 so if
companies choose to are forced to go
public we will see a pickup in the
amount of IPOs but if they're forced to
go public the question is will the
market allow them to go public only
companies with a robust long duration
business model will be able to access
the public markets the public markets
have become very discerning in January
we did not have an IPO exactly we didn't
have an IPO because the flow of funds
into the public markets we're not there
you know to do an IPO you need new
investors you need capital becoming in
the market if you're an asset allocator
today or you're running a mutual fund or
you're a big investor you're probably
pretty fully invested too
if I bring you a new IPO for you to be
able to buy that IPO you need one of two
things to happen you have to sell a
position you already own and think that
the IPO is a more favorable rate of
return than something you own or what's
a better outcome is you need to be
getting positive inflows in every day
and you have to put those to work and
the IPO is a great place to put them to
work we haven't been seeing positive
inflows in the market in fact we've been
seeing outflows from the market so until
we get inflows in the market or we get a
change in valuation of the IPOs it's
going to be somewhat difficult for some
of these companies go public that said
we think we will get a normalization
evaluations we think that many of these
companies will be able able to go public
as the markets continue to settle down
or when the market settle down